I hid behind a big tree that was knocked down or fallen.
And I could see these Germans in the woods across this big field.
And I saw this young kid crawling up a ditch straight towards my tree.
So, I let him crawl. I didn't fire at him.
But when he got up within three or four foot of me,...
...I screamed at him to surrender.
And instead of surrendering, he started to pull his gun towards me...
...which was instant death for him.
But this young man, he was blonde, blue eyes, fair-skinned, so handsome.
He was like a little angel but I still had to shoot him.
And it didn't bother me the first night...
...because I went to sleep and I was so tired.
But the second night, I woke up crying because that kid was dead.
And to this day, I wake up many nights crying.
I still see him in my dreams.
And I don't know how to get him off my mind.